je crois que nous avons je marque je
crois que monsieur pierre debray qui est
le mari de madame sabran terminé quand
même de surgir pour donner son avis le
bras il a semblé de port de grâce est en
train de nous traiter de véhicules
commandés moche ça c'est moi j'ai pas
oui au tout quand vous vous voterez
comme ça veut dire du cochon invasif
choses et je défends cohn bendit cavache
c'est je crois une soirée suffisamment
sérieuse si vous pensez que ma place
n'est pas souhaitable puisque la droite
elle a gagné moi je laisse la place à la
droite je vais ailleurs il entend alors
là aussi rien dire avant la fin d'une
mission je parte à pompe
messieurs mitterrand parce que moi
j'avais plein de notes en venant dans
notre nation non je n'aurai pas le temps
je le sais déjà j'ai pas le temps est
juste le temps de mettre en colère je
voulais commencer maintenant
non c'est le système de la formation
française qui fait comme ça j'aurai le
temps une minute de m'énerver juste de
m'énerver de paraître pour un petit
merdeux un petit jeune de la pagaille
carproof est pas choquant mais le choc
pour moi je vais pas sûr qu'ils n'ont
rien dit pour l'instant c'est
extrêmement désagréable de discuter avec
vous je crois que les syndicats ont
raison de protester contre le fait que
l'information avec vous sur antenne 2 a
du mal à s'exprimer
georges marchais on s'en fout de georges
marchais il faut le savoir ça de ce
qu'il faisait pendant la guerre ça nous
c'est complètement égal j'ai peut-être
du culot de faire ça je suis obligé de
le faire comme ça parce que je dois
faire vite
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que la
jeunesse se désespère les jeunes vont
finir par virer du mauvais côté parce
qu'ils n'auront plus d'autre solution
voilà je vous remercie d'avoir laissé
parler